AT HAND.
IT WILL BE
SCORE.
DILLON DUBE HITSALLOWS DILLON D
MATT DUCHENE  REMAIN IN THE BOX
FOR THE MOMENT.
BACK T
YOU TALK ABOUT A
BE HEADING OVER THERE.
>> Chris: WE ARE GOING THROUGH
THE ROSTER.  VLADAR  TO TIE THI
CAGE!IT FLUTTER.
IS TRYING TO SHOOT IT AND D
MATCHUP. BOTH ! FILIP
FORSBERG IS OVER THERE ALL
ALONE.
FEEDS IT RIGHT THROUGH THE
SAME, AND IS IN.SEEN.
THE SECOND ONE TO
GOAL OF THE YEAR TO TIE IT UP.
THIS ONE SKIPPING AR
HE OUTSTRETCHED THE BUZZER.
LOOK AT THE WHOLE RIGHT THERE.
UNBELIEVABLE. AND
LESS THAN
LINDHOLM,DAN VLADAR, THEY NEVER
SHOT.
GUDBRANSON SIX SPEEOPTION AWAY.
LOOKING TO STICK IN THE SCREEN
AN
MATT DUCHENE  STAYS IN. SHOT,
IT TRICKLES ACROSS THE LINE.
FLAMES WIN.